by the way we you know there was a wall
of skepticism from the media like they
just like everybody was just like yeah
this is the great this is just like bomb
this is not you know this is not for
regular people at that time
um and so you had to think through that
and then look it was still yeah it was
still hard to get on the internet at
that point right so you could get kind
of this weird bastardized version if
you're on AOL which wasn't really real
or you had to go like learn what an ISP
was
um you know in those days PCS actually
didn't have TCP drivers come
pre-installed so you had to learn what a
tcpip driver was you had to buy a modem
you had to install driver software
um I have a comedy routine I do
something like 20 minutes long
describing all the steps required to
actually get on the internet at this
point
um and so you had to you had to look
through these practical well and then
and then uh and then speed performance
14-4 modems right like it was like
watching you know glue dry um like and
so you had to you had to they were
basically a sequence of bets that we
made where you basically needed to look
through that current state of affairs
and say actually there's going to be so
much demand for that once people figure
this out there's gonna be so much demand
for it that all of these practical
problems are going to get fixed yes some
people say that the anticipation makes
the
the destination that much more exciting
do you remember Progressive jpegs yeah
do I do I so forget for kids in the
audience right for kids you used to have
to watch an image load like a line at a
time but it turns out there was this
thing with jpegs where you could you
could load basically every fourth you
could load like every fourth uh line and
then and then you could sweep back
through again and so you could like
render a fuzzy version image up front
and then it would like resolve into the
detailed one and that was like a big UI
breakthrough because it gave you
something to watch
yeah and uh you know there's
applications in various domains for that
uh
it was a big fight but there was a big
fight early on about whether there
should be images on the web
um for that reason for like
sexualization no not not explicit that
did come up but it wasn't even that it
was more just like all the serious the
argument went the purists basically said
all the serious information the world is
text if you introduce images you you
basically going to bring in all the
trivial stuff you're going to bring in
magazines and you know all this crazy
y'all just you know stuff that you know
people you know it's going to distract
from it's going to go take take away
from being serious being frivolous